here in central kiev a very symbolic
moment is taking place right now i'm
standing under the friendship arch
underneath the arch is a statue the
statue speaks to the friendship the
unity the work between ukraine and
russia on one side you see a ukrainian
man holding up a symbol with a russian
man this entire statue will be taken
down workers started however with the
russian man that is depicted here they
took off his head first now in just
speaking with the mayor of kiev he made
a point of saying this statue no longer
speaks to ukraine or ukrainians that
there is not a friendship there is not a
sense of unity and togetherness that
there once was when this was put up past
soviet times he is proposing that it be
changed that something takes the place
of this current statute that addresses
the independence of ukraine the freedoms
of ukraine and possibly this big freedom
arch that i'm just standing under right
now that might even be repainted into
the colors of the ukrainian flag a fair
number of people and of course many many
journalists here to witness this
historic moment and it really does speak
to the feeling right now in ukraine the
feeling of of pride the feeling of a
sense of having to separate themselves
from russia and make a point that they
are distinct that they are different
that's also something i heard from the
president of the national security and
defense council when i interviewed him
he was talking about the pride he has
not only and ukrainian soldiers but all
ukrainians talked about the ongoing
efforts of this war and he also talked
specifically about the role the rest of
the world will play and we'll have more
of that interview coming up a little bit
later tonight crystal mansion global
news